and indeed it is the Queen of Hearts
Thank You Jeremiah for your potpourri of
prestidigitation for the past hour from
pulling up magic tricks to kicking butt
Patrick John Pflueger isn't the dorky
dude from The Princess Diaries anymore
he's all grown up shredded and bearded
and starring on a Chicago PD
I just want to make sure that you and I
on the same page since his Princess
Diaries days
Patrick start on the USA original series
the 4400 you you're not quite there yet
and hit the big screen in 2011's
Footloose remake you fall behind you're
gonna get hit by the leader pull ahead
you just might get slammed by the guy in
last place it's certainly not hard
playing Julian Huff's boyfriend oh man
but since 2014 he's been officer Adam
ruzek in the NBC Chicago verse that one
you know that stand up say it again
right now take this badge off right now
man but don't worry he's still got some
of jeremías class clown spirit in real
life we got a nice derriere shot of this
one it follows me everywhere
you
[Music]